intermountain healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment want to remind you
that physical and mental health go hand
in hand so we stopped by their new
behavioral health clinic to learn more
check it out
i want to welcome you to our new
cheyenne behavioral health clinic which
we just recently opened to take care of
the behavioral health needs of our
patients
and to tell us a little more i'd like to
introduce latisha morgan one of our
therapists
hi so mental health integration here at
intermountain encompasses the whole
person we like to not only take care of
their physical health but their mental
health studies have shown that if you
can take care of both you have better
results our behavioral health program is
designed to be a team approach starting
with our primary care providers in the
office recognizing that you may need
some additional assistance
our behavioral health team or mental
health integration team is comprised of
two nurse practitioners who can
prescribe medications to help you as
well as six licensed clinical social
workers like leticia
so recognizing that you're the most
important person of your team for your
mental health we like to work in a
collaborative approach and so talking to
your primary care physician really helps
us understand the dynamics and the needs
and you're the expert so you're
providing us with the information that
we need to also work with the aprns to
see if there's medication that is needed
as well as working with the social
workers and the nurse case managers to
see if there are other resources in the
community that we can provide to assist
in other areas we like to look at the
whole person not just your mental health
or your physical health but other things
that you may need we work with community
partners in providing transportation
meals and other identified areas that
you may need assistance in recognizing
that you're the most important person to
this team we like to ask for your
permission to invite your family to be a
collaborative member of the team
approach your doctor is the team leader
who makes a recommendation to behavioral
health either to the aprns for
medication management or to the mental
health professionals for psychotherapy
sometimes they recommend for both and
that's okay we also utilize the nurse
case managers and social workers to
assist in providing different resources
in the community through therapy and
medication management we're able to make
adjustments to help you and the
different areas of your life whether it
be through depression anxiety or other
adjustments that you're experiencing at
the moment sometimes that may be grief
or even financial we're here to help and
assist in all areas of your life to make
you the best person that you can be
located in north las vegas we're close
to our patients that may need some extra
help in getting to the office this puts
it in their community so that it's much
easier for them to access the health
that they need
the other aspect is with our care
managers and social workers we continue
to work with you and your family on
meeting the social determinants of
health the things that you need to be
successful such as
food housing transportation clothing
we'll work with our case managers and
social workers to help you meet those
needs we also have an abundance of
educational programs to help you keep
you up to date on the latest in
healthcare and behavioral health if you
find that you or a friend are in need of
behavioral health therapy what we would
urge you to do is go to your primary
care provider's office and they can
submit a referral to get you to see one
of our providers once we receive that
referral we want to make sure you're
comfortable and break the stigma of
mental health
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring that segment head to
intermountainhealthcare.org nevada for
more information in las vegas now we'll
be
you